[Music]
what would you say the theme of the
season is I would say my thing for the
show would be it's like old drama it's
like it's like it's almost like why are
we so having the same conversation like
unresolved issues yeah yeah unsolved
mysteries she married a thing yeah I
just want why are you so involved in my
life I'm a really you know good friend
of Kenya so I wasn't a loop a lot more
than some of the other ladies were but I
did not know that she was getting
married and I was about that like I
would have left I've been there have you
met the man yet I have okay he's real he
exists Mart Daly is very much real and
he's awesome and as soon as I got
divorced she got married so she's got
left me Phaedra why didn't you admit you
started the rumor was it weird to come
back after everything that went down at
last year's reunion Wow you know last
year last year's reunion was really
really really dark and it was just sad
it was like what in the world is going
on like this show is all about shade and
drama when it just gets to the point
where you can just make up the most
ridiculous lies on people and carry it
out this just might be too dirty for me
if this is what we're gonna do now
because it's hard to defend a lie it's
very hurtful and it's very sad and you
know I will say this about Phaedra you
know we came on the show together I
always felt like you know we had a
connection because we kind of started
this journey together so I mean I do you
know miss having her around but at the
same time you know I just you know I
just couldn't agree with what she did
would you ever want her
to come back into the group and be on
the show again in the future I think
there has to be some boundaries that
just can't be crossed and you know it's
not up to the cast to make those
decisions with that said I thought
failure was great chef I thought she was
hilarious on show so I would never say
that I don't think anyone that has been
on the show shouldn't come back because
I think everybody brings different
things I really really honestly do but I
do feel like you know it definitely was
a wake-up call for other people in the
show that might have felt like they
could just you know fallen in her
footsteps
notice it's not gonna be tolerated
[Music]
you
[Music]